hello everyone I hope they are good
because I am yesterday's production
played out perfectly
um I'll go again through the analysis so
you know we can see it in hand side too
um this was so we can range over here
okay and then on weekends
um but I always tell you the same we
usually see some kind of a range because
there is not much volatility and not
much liquidity in the market okay so uh
usually also what you see on Mondays are
a false move okay back with a bit to the
upside or to the downside
um I chose for different reasons to the
upside okay
um to me the first one for Monday
was confirmed by this poop during the
Asian session because usually most Asian
pumps get retraced right so when I See
Asia pumping like this non-stop I don't
trust that move all right now if you
notice here we were saying that London
needed to hold in this Zone over here
they did that's perfect and they said
this retail resistance trend line okay
is this one that you have marked let me
Mark it in yellow so you can see it
better okay that one there so that's
your retail resistant line and you know
that the retail if they are gonna
position in shorts they're gonna play
the rest stop losses right above this
resistance line okay so that's when you
can think the Via of a stophunt by The
Cure you can see here if you go to the
50 minutes time frame you can even see a
better here how you know you just follow
the line it's insane okay but then you
have the stop hundred between the four
hour 50ma and the daily 50 I mean we see
that doesn't was a very big resistance
and then you can see press done but now
over expecting price When I See Asia
pumping
then what I need is to see London
holding at the highest okay because if
London comes all the way here then you
know I'm not interested because there is
no much profit in this Zone but if he
holds here you have all of this room for
profit okay so that's that's what you
need to see
um then if London holds you can imagine
seeing are right at the start of the New
York session that's why I made this line
over here and he followed it
why because many Traders are waiting for
the new year session to open and if they
start to see New York pumping they're
gonna say okay we're gonna have a
bullish session I'm gonna go long okay
so in here where the market maker is
essentially doing is hitting the short
stop losses and also trapping breakout
traders to the upside okay Traders I
think that prices will not continue
going higher
that's why also it's very important to
know where your 50 Mas are in high time
frame because you know that here you
have the 15-minute daily timeframe this
line purple line is the 50 I mean the
daily time frame this is a massive
resistance again my trade would have
been invalidated when we saw something
like this okay because then you know the
price and continue higher but that's
your validation that's why you always
have to plan in validation now you can
see it in New York
after the stophunt didn't do much really
you know it continued holding in this
Zone over here and closed in this one
um but then here
you have the chance to go short again
okay if you didn't catch this stop front
here okay for example you could have
entered here
blindly
um I waited and I didn't because I
wanted to see if they were gonna hit the
50ma first so then when I saw this
candle okay closing below it this red
candle then I was looking for entry
points okay
um I don't remember what I entered I was
in the 400 Zone uh but again I don't
know if it was limited to figure it out
um could it be in one of these scandals
maybe it could be
um then
um a place would equal to a half enter
again is in this one here because you
can see the price goes well the New York
session closes here okay in this candle
here and then you can see price is
getting rejected at the 50 main the 15
minutes time frame so that's your
confirmation
that price might continue going down in
the Asian session all right
um at that time I didn't even check the
charts um I mean I only had the chart
like this because I was on my phone
and just by looking how price was you
know developing I knew what I had a
feeling that Acer was going to dump but
you mean it shown to be more technical
then yes you had this confirmation here
that we are right now below resistance
all right
um so that I hope that was clear
um let's go to the one hour time frame
um I want to show you that I haven't
moved the lines you know they just
magically follow it if we check this
this is what I posted on Twitter after
the video okay this was during the
London session
okay let me see so you can see better
and you're gonna be able to see
that I haven't moved anything all right
this just happened
you mean
it's it almost went perfect you can see
it's it's amazing honestly how the
trading sessions work
um also in the Sunday update I was
saying that
there was no really big announcements
this week so you could expect to see the
psychological uh weekly pattern and the
trading systems player now better this
week okay you also have to know
by looking at the context of the week
that you are in
um what type of strategies you can you
can do in a more efficient way and in my
case I had it very clear that it was the
psychological weekly pattern and also
the trading sessions I I thought they
were gonna play a well and also more
that you can see the first day they
played oh well okay so that's good why
not let's move to the next thing what do
I think price is up to okay what do I
think Bitcoin might do next
um okay we've been saying
that we have this week here to the
downside okay this week to the downside
is quite uh I would say suspicious all
right because you can see that it's a
week of
um
the pump from the week are two percent
exactly so you can see the price goes
from 25 800 to
26 318 so that's a 500 dollars
Wick in the photo time frame and in the
one hour time frame is very similar you
can see here it's extremely similar okay
it closes at 26 302 okay so it's almost
the same candle the same week
um that's why I think that we're gonna
come back to this week now uh on the
Sunday update you'll remember that what
I was anticipating was this let me go to
the one hour time frame
um I was telling you that we have the
weekend range here
for you guys
this is your weekend range and then I
was projecting
false move on Monday we've got it and
then during the rest of the week until
Wednesday or Thursday you could see the
weak strand okay and that would be
towards that week
um it could be 50 of the week the week
or even sweep of the lows okay but at
least the 50 of the week has to get
filled so that will take off somewhere
like this and then if we see
you know if we continue seeing price
going down today and tomorrow then I
would suggest that Wednesday or Thursday
to close a short style profit okay
because it's useful that during the mid
week Wednesday or Thursday you see some
kind of reversal okay and I could take
you again to maybe that weekend trains
again all right so obviously why are you
going to prefer to close your shorts if
you open shorts in this Zone okay or do
you want to prefer to close them here
to close them here of course yeah right
if you are in profit this week this week
is going to be an interesting one
because some things are developing for
example we have now the problem of that
ceiling okay and they want to try to
close a deal
for this week I believe that when I
close a deal I know that you know there
is some people
um that won't care saying that oh they
might not agree and extended that
ceiling
um I think that's very unlikely because
everybody knows that if that happens the
economy of the United States would go
would go to the floor so
um that are adding pressure to each
other asking for demands about the
underground
like they've done before that's what I
think now is it possible that it close
the deal this week that's what I don't
know okay I'll have a crystal ball but
they are talking about it I think today
is Tuesday yes today we have a meeting
President Biden with
um the house Speaker McCarthy so let's
see what they say in a meeting
um it might not be something that big
but be ready for any big news okay that
beef come to an agreement
um through during this week that could
potentially make a move okay I'm trying
to figure it out
I'm still trying to think how the market
would react to it okay how the s p will
react to it because in a way yes I mean
is is the only choice that you have as
it's still a bad choice okay
um it might be priced in he might be
priced in but the the moment that those
news are released saying that they've
come to an agreement there is gonna be I
expect a lot of volatility in the market
okay so you mean be be careful that it
doesn't catch you in a in a high level
straight
that's what I'm telling you
um
in Bull markets when everything goes up
yes you can maybe take more leverage
trades but now in a better Market is a
market purely driven by data you have to
be very careful okay because any
anything that a president or a CEO says
it can literally shake the market Okay
so
I will tell you stay tuned with the news
it's quite important in this type of
environment
um this I'm expecting this week to get
filled hopefully uh we can see getting
filled this week
but if we don't see getting filled this
week that's still gonna be our Target
for maybe next week okay because I think
that this week I mean 500 a week in the
one hour and the four-hour time it needs
to get filled it's as simple as that
I would say that one of the keys is to
try to think like a retail Trader
sometimes okay because
um the things like a market make it if
you don't know how the retail Trader
thinks okay
um now I know probably many Traders are
starting to draw some kind of trend
lines like this
um to be honest I don't even know how to
draw it but uh maybe something like this
I don't know maybe the wrong trend lines
like this and they'll say Okay price
won't go from here
price went up from here again from here
from here to so when this happens okay
um just imagine that if price comes to
the standard line again
the retail Traders when I place Longs
okay in mind what would happen if one of
these times it might be this time maybe
the next one price just goes down okay
that is gonna be a lot of traders that
have buy well long limit orders in this
trend line that are going to be
underwater and they're gonna get stopped
well stop it if they will have a stop
loss
okay so that's adding you today via the
price you know it's it's behaving like
this but price will eventually come down
or at least that's what I think okay
um now is it possible that we see some
kind of uh you know quite an aggressive
push first to bring price down again
um I don't discard it um but I think
this will take longer to play out or at
least that's what I think okay
um for now thinking more about
psychological uh weekly pattern
that is the weekend range mod is force
move then you have the weak strength
from Tuesday until Wednesday or Thursday
to the downside okay maybe to fill this
week and then a little retrace okay so
that's why I'm keeping an eye on both of
course
um I can't dismiss the idea that they're
gonna do a bigger prompt here okay and
then they can bring price on again
um because yes usually when you see also
trending like this okay
um it's normal to see right before the
breakdown I've seen many times before
that they do quite aggressive move so
then there is gonna be a lot of people
that have the feel that they have missed
out on this boom so that I want to wait
again for the touch of this trend line
to go long heavily okay and that's when
they drop it
so yes that's another scenario okay
again if this plays out I don't think
this would be this week I think it would
take uh longer to to come all the way to
the week so
um yes what I what I mean to say is that
if we see a pump like this this week
then forget about the week in the next
week all right
um now let's go to higher block see if
we can find some liquidity some
liquidations okay
um see if they can add from Confluence
to our chart okay we're in hablo Capital
let's see how these liquidations are
looking
okay well in the seven days time frame
let's have a look oh wow okay there is
color liquidity to the upside to be
honest uh to the downside twenty six
thousand four hundred but there is a lot
more to the upside at least in in lower
time frame okay uh you have a lot of
liquidity at 27
827 850 and also a 28 400 okay
um this Zone you know imagine with the
previous High because there is always
liquidity about above previous highs and
Below previous lows you can have a look
here what happened okay you have a high
then there is a lot of liquidity above
the high
and price comes back to it okay I'll hit
these liquidations could we see them
same thing happening now might be that's
why I'm telling you that the second is
near the love story about that train
line with the final push up
if I happen all right for now I'm gonna
say that I'm still favoring uh the hook
to the downside uh during the rest of
the week but uh it's pretty much because
we are below all the key 50 amazed I
mean in in our time frames in the one
hour time frame I think we're below it
in the fourth time frame in the daily
time frame also in this zone is a daily
50ma so in this one it's likely to see
some kind of rejection okay but if we
for example start to go above
the 4 Hour 50ma then uh this is the
second necessarily will be more likely
to happen and we might see you know a
touch of the daily 50ma for once then in
the one month time frame let's have a
look
let's see if we can see something
interesting
um let's get this on
okay you can see that the Heat or loose
liquidations that we were pointing out I
don't know if you remember uh also this
week we knew this was a force move
because we this bounce it was around for
liquidity to gather even more
liquidations here because the rater
wasn't all per locks with this bounce
and then we need pressure when I come to
these liquidations they did and now
if you notice uh it's looking quite I
would say quiet it's looking quiet in
this one here you can see a cruise state
of liquidations at 33 300 but again
that's a that's a
um above previous highs uh I think
you'll be able to see here
very easy okay so you can see that those
were your highs that's a resistance Zone
and above resistance you have all these
calculations okay so it makes sense and
on the three months time frame
let's see because I think this one gets
even more interesting
okay let's see what we got here
I mean you can see that the closest
amount of liquidations are still below
us at 25 25 400 okay what matches with
the resistance that we had for for
qualones on time we had two sell-offs
from this point 25 400 and we haven't
seen a support yet so you know if we
continue going lower from the daily 50 I
mean or even if we see now a push to the
valley 15 and then we get a reaction
again and we cannot get above it then
we're expecting 25 400 doesn't to get
tested and also you can see that there
is quite a lot of liquidations there
um then of course to the alarm side if
we lose that zone
the 25 000 soon uh 22 000 should come
next and if we you know if we break
above the daily 50ma whole little
support again like we did in this this
time over here okay this was I think in
10 days we tested the daily 50ma I
support six times so if we you know if
we recover the daily 50ma tested our
support then yes you can go for all this
liquidity above right but for now we
have to play what what the market gives
us and for right if you check the chart
we are below the daily 50ma the 4 Hour
50ma so I'm not going to open any Longs
here okay I'm gonna be favoring the week
to the bouncy to get filled first okay
which is around 26 050. say 26 000 give
or take right so that's pretty much
everything guys uh click careful and
stay tuned with the news
I know sounds sounds weird well I think
it's an important week to stay tuned
with the news also there is going to be
a lot of
um
fomc officers uh speaking they're gonna
give a lot of speeches so they might you
know they might sleep up and give us
some clues about what could happen next
in the economy okay um yes that will
trigger a lot of liquidity so I hope
that this video was helpful that I was
clear
um thank you so much for watching and
I'll see you soon